Welcome to another episode of playing
with myself, name tentative, but I'll be
honest at this point I'm just waiting
for someone to be annoyed enough to give
me a better name in the comment section
because I'm out of ideas, man. I'm out
of ideas. So, anyways, today we are
featuring a different deck with Belbe
Bertolt. If you've seen the deck tech,
you know this deck has one and only one
game plan. To keep Belbe alive and
growing. That's it. And this is supposed
to fend off whatever your opponents can
throw at us. Sounds good, but how does
it work in practice? We are about to
find out. And once again, we have a
selection that is an attempt to recreate
the average Commander night table with
some of the most popular choices. Our
first new opponent is none other than
number two in the all-time Commanders
list, Edgar Markov. Now, I know if you
focus on the Eminence ability and abuse
it, Edgar has potential to be much
higher than bracket three, but I just
want a nice vampire tribal deck, you
know, where I can play the fanciest, the
coolest vampires I own. So, it might not
be the most powerful or consistent Edgar
deck, but even then, this deck should
sit comfortably at bracket three and be
able to dish out some solid beatdowns.
Our next opponent is Sauron representing
hard control with the dirtiest tricks
that Grixis has to offer. Sauron
provides reliable way to win the game
with our massive orc army. Combined with
unblockable and red's unique form of
evasion, we have finishers without
having to resort to combo. And finally,
we have a returning guest in Belbe
artifacts, another explosive all-in
strategy that seeks to apply pressure
early. Can Belbe gold everything? We
will find out.
Okay, we are going to figure out the
starting player. We are starting with
Sauron.
Being a control deck, we really do
appreciate the head start because we're
against, yeah, two really aggressive,
really fast
opponents.
Uh okay, we got
I don't know.
Okay, this saves the day because we can
turn three talisman,
uh turn two talisman, and turn three
relic, and we are pretty much online,
and we just need some draw spells and
worst case this can be a draw spell
right or we can just get an early Sauron
out to turn on the deadly relic so seems
reasonable.
Keep.
It's below draw land coat of arms.
Okay, this is very good.
We have our color oh semblance sample is
nice.
Give me a land give
This is a good hand because we can
semblance sample on turn turn three
and then all these will be cheap and the
mightstone can draw us cards so this is
a very good hand.
I'll keep Okay, let's take a look at
Bayonets draw draw Okay, as per sentinel
is very good.
Yeah, this is looking great actually
give me one land we got it okay.
Yeah, turn one as per sentinel will give
us so much value.
So this is definitely a keep even
without the land
we still keep it.
I think it's worth it.
So looking at the game we are kind of a
late game deck.
But we are staring down two really
aggressive opponents in Edgar and Bello.
Another problem is that we are not going
to win the late game against Sauron so
we have to kind of
divert these two opponents into Sauron
and that's what our commander is built
to do.
But we need to get Bayonets out as soon
as possible. Another problem
with this game is that Bello for Bello
the artifacts are four fours. Meanwhile
Bayonets has to be out for at least a
turn to gold anything that's five power
or lower. Yeah, Bayonets just coming out
isn't enough to gold Bello so we need to
play Bayonets along with the background
and keep him around for a turn. So
that's going to be a challenge
but we'll see how it goes. Keep Edgar.
Land tax is great. Oh wow wow okay, this
is good.
I I this is already a keep. I mean we
need another land, but we got the other
land, but we need a white source.
Now, we're fine. We're fine. This is
Yeah, this is easily a keep.
So, we have one drop. We have Land Tax.
Yeah, we can drop Land Tax on turn two.
That's no problem.
And hopefully we draw something slightly
earlier than turn four. A three drop
perhaps. Uh that would be great. But so
far this is fine. Maybe not amazing, but
it's a fine hand to keep. Let's play.
All right. Sorin
draw.
Ooh, this is also very good.
Yeah, this is a really sweet hand
actually. I like it.
Land. Pass.
One moment.
Already misplayed. We should play a
tapped land first.
Pass. Belbe, draw.
Mirari Works.
Land. Pass. Belbe lost his very happy
about this because no one's dropped a
Sol Ring yet. So, yeah. Esper Sentinel
is going to get max value.
Nice. Edgar draws a land. Play a swamp
for a turn one with Serra's here. Let's
get a vampire token. Pass. Sorin untaps.
Draw.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure we're going to
have to play things cuz vampire is is
already building and we have to keep up.
So, yeah, whatever. Let
Belbe draw us cards. Belbe draw us card
and pass the turn. Belbe
Yeah, it looks like we are just ignoring
Esper Sentinel. Not sure if this is
correct, but everyone is doing things.
And also, you know, Edgar doesn't need
to play mana rocks. Edgar is going to
go creature into creature into creature
which we can't keep up with unless we do
something. So, we do that and
Belbe draw us card.
Pass.
Wow, this is good. We just need more
mana rocks. I mean, Mind Stone is
excellent, but
maybe Let's see if we can draw a Sol
Ring or something that will propel us
into a prime position to win the game.
Pass. Draw. Oh, this is good. This is
good.
But we start off with a Lantus.
Yeah, next turn we can drop cloud.
And uh
get some value.
So this we're paying for the S percent
now and we're going to attack Beloth.
Seems like the obvious target now.
Pass the turn.
Okay, Sauron.
Uh draw.
Ooh, Baral.
Not the best
top deck, but
serviceable. So why don't we play Relic
of Sauron?
Do we run Baral out there? We don't have
any
spells to reduce costs with, but do we
uh I don't think so. I think we hold. So
this uh what did we pay? Uh we played
this, right? Uh the relic. So then
another draw for Beloth.
You know what? I think we play Baral
just because
it's not like he's going to do too much
late game anyways and uh we There are a
lot of draw spells that are draw X.
So
could be
value if we get something like that.
And also a blocker.
Pass the turn. Bello untaps, draw.
Okay, now we are going to pay the tax,
four mana
for Simbelmynë
Oops.
Here you go.
And we're going to exile Coat of Arms
because this is not something we will
use anytime soon. And hopefully this
stays and we can have a wonderful mid
game.
Hopefully this can stick around and our
turn five and six will be value into
value into value.
Looking forward to that.
Untap.
Draw.
Ooh.
Land.
So we try to go for an early Beloth, but
we do need to set up a few things like
Champion's Helm.
Mirage Mirror is sweet, but what can we
use it for right now?
Not much, right now. Much. So, let's
Yeah, play a land, play a champion's
helm.
Pass the turn.
Edgar, let's trigger Lantax. Why not?
We don't want to top deck too many
basics. Let's send a message to the
deck.
Okay, turns out we don't have a lot of
basics in the deck. So, I will just
search for one. Maybe leave one or two
in the deck just in case something comes
up that requires basic searching.
Like fable passage, for example.
Okay, draw.
So, we are going to play a land. We're
going to play collab.
We've run out of empire tokens, so this
will do. And we're going to keep
attacking Beloth. Seems correct. Attack.
Oops.
Attack. And meanwhile, we are going to
mark our vampire here.
I guess this one cuz it can be a chump
blocker.
So, let's mark this vampire
with collab.
And
later we'll get some value. Pass.
Sauron is feeling great. This is turn
four.
We have seven mana and we are at 40
life.
We just need some gas. Okay, this is
gas. Explosive iteration.
Let's play a land. Not yet. Maybe we
play a land. We'll see what land we get
with the iteration.
So, we might as well use the relic.
Let's use the relic for explosive
iteration.
We look at two cards, uh three cards.
Chaos warp.
Draw spell. And we are
we are cooking.
So, I think we put Oath of Tomorrow into
hand.
Mhm.
Do we cast chaos warp this turn?
Don't see much of a target.
So, I think we take transpose.
And Chaos Warp can go on the bottom.
This might be very greedy, but we again
we are
off to a pretty good start.
Oh, meanwhile Belzenlok draws a card.
There you go.
And we are going to
transpose, I suppose.
Yeah, we haven't played a land yet, so
transpose,
lose a life, draw a card, then discard a
card.
I think we can discard a land here. We
don't really need the budget Golgari.
Meanwhile, we create a token. Okay, we
create a wizard token and yeah, play a
land and might as well drop another
rock.
And now we pass the turn. Oh, looks like
we untapped with Semblance Anvil. That
is very good. Draw, okay. Yeah, see
these are just free.
So, first we are going to drop a
Mightstone.
1 2 3 three mana.
Do we pay the extra? I want to say no
because we are going to chain this into
this into more things, so
yeah, I think we're using that mana. And
Belzenlok already have enough cards, I'm
guessing.
So,
we then draw two cards. Is there
anything to remove? I guess we can
remove the Esper Sentinel, but once
again,
it's like it's not my problem anymore.
Like
they've drawn five, six cards already
and we should just develop our own board
at this point.
Again, this mindset might not be right.
We should take responsibility and do the
right thing
but we don't. Draw one,
two.
And look at that, we got rewarded kind
of. We play this for free.
1 2 3
mana
for
Eternity Elevator.
Three mana four. Mirrorworks.
And I think we pass.
Yeah, we can play Mox Diamond. We don't
really need to.
This
The difference is this doesn't attack.
Meanwhile, all of these can attack next
turn. So
and we will play a land
and pass.
Bayloff untaps.
Draw.
It's sweet we drew so many cards, but
most of them are lands. That's annoying.
So we are going to play an Opal Palace.
Then we drop the Noble Heritage. Is that
correct?
Yeah, let's set up for Bayloff.
Meanwhile, we have three mana in case we
need to counter something.
Maybe.
Next turn we can Bayloff and then
protect it with Talents Gate.
And that That sounds good so that it
will almost guarantee to survive and we
will have a six power Bayloff.
And we're at 38 life. We're not under
too much immediate pressure. Although I
think we might have forgot to take uh we
forgot to take two damage. Right? Cuz we
got attacked twice. So we should
actually be at 36. My apologies. But
yeah, this is the turn. Can we equip?
Plus one to equip. Yeah, sure. As a
blocker, right? Let's equip our Esper
Sentinel because we don't need that
extra mana. And now it's a 3/3. No
hexproof because it's not legendary, but
3/3.
Now we can block somethings. Pass the
turn. End of turn, we are going to
sacrifice this vampire with Viscera
Seer. So it becomes a 4/3.
Uh wings, I guess. Vampire D Vampire
Demon.
And we draw a card.
And we scry one.
Ooh, Vanquisher's Banner is good. We
want that.
Think.
Let's keep it. Okay, on top. Draw. Play
a land.
Which land do we play? Just a mountain.
Now, I guess we keep attacking, but who?
On this board, actually, I think Sauron
is stronger.
It's hard to say. Sauron has three cards
in hand, but
uh I guess we can try to split it.
So, 4 3 into Beloth
while this vampire
and this vampire will attack Sauron.
Yeah, it's not that much damage. More
importantly, we are marking this
vampire.
Okay.
And for Sauron, we are going to block
because they can sack anyways. Might as
well block.
Or uh actually, let's let's prevent two
damage rather than one. So, let's block
here.
And uh Beloth doesn't block. So, here we
take one. Beloth takes 1 2 3 4. Wasn't
the best split attack, probably, but
oh, well. We are vampires. We are done.
So,
land for a Ange. Ange, Falkenrath. And
we get a token. You can see my art
getting sloppier and sloppier. Pass.
Okay, Sauron again is feeling excellent
about this board. We draw
for Smari Command. I think the play here
is just to hold the fort and do a big
pull from tomorrow.
And uh yeah, take over the game with
that new hand.
So,
I
And I want to play this as a land.
I go pretty far out of my way to hit my
land drops, especially in a control deck
where we are never short on cards. I'm
not sure if it's correct, but yeah, I
like again playing this as a land to me
seems very reasonable.
Especially when we have a draw spell.
Yeah, I like my land drops. So, pass the
turn.
Okay, untap with Beloth.
Draw.
Cloud Key. Not what we need right now.
So, as bellow here, I'm thinking this is
our chance.
Our the artifact deck is explosive, but
it's also very vulnerable.
And yeah, this board shouldn't stick for
long. So, what we should do now is we
should do as much damage as possible.
But, at the same time with Sauron having
all this mana open
I want to attack Sauron. Sauron is
clearly ahead.
But, I think we split the damage. Yeah,
we try to split the damage a little bit
so that Sauron doesn't kill Bello or
wipe our board. Like, they might have a
cycle on the grip or something. Yeah,
what the weakness with Bello is that
Bello, the moment Bello dies, our entire
attack falls apart. Uh we do have a lot
of protection spells, but we didn't draw
them.
So,
let's cast Bello. Just three mana.
And we go into combat. Unfortunately, I
think we have to send two uh to Beloth
and one at Sauron.
We want to draw cards.
And Beloth will not block.
Yeah, we don't want to lose anything.
Not our S percent no. This can still
give us value, especially now that it's
a 3-3.
So, we take eight damage. Ouch, that
hurts. We need Beloth down ASAP. 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8. Meanwhile, this attack makes it
so Sauron really doesn't want to use a
removal on Bello. Also, because paying
three for this, we lose our pull for
tomorrow.
So, I do we block it?
Yeah, I think this wizard doesn't do
that much, so we'll block to save four
life. I think it's worth it. So, in the
end, Bello draws two cards.
Madera
two lands.
Okay, we can play a land normally.
Unfortunately, we didn't get more
artifacts. Actually, I want to play
Talion's Gate now. I was thinking
activating Talion Gates to ramp, but
ramp is not our problem. Our problem is
card draw. So, I want to play Talion
Gates now to save the mana for War Room.
Play it. We're going to exile Belorth.
Not exile. We're going to
face up Belorth to protect him for a
turn. And that's our turn.
Pass. Untap.
Yeah, we are feeling the pressure.
But, I think we can cast our commander
now, right? Play a land. We are one mana
short of doing commander and this. Also,
we don't get to equip. So, I'm tempted
to say we
don't don't play this land and we Talion
Gates our commander.
Next turn, we can potentially take
a lot of damage actually. So, hmm this
is difficult. So, we want 5 + 1 + 2
mana. We want eight mana. Right now, we
have 1 2 3 4 5 with a land drop, six
mana.
So,
I'm thinking how about we play a land
and just pass. Cuz if we do that, we can
hold up Talion Gates,
which can remove something. We can which
can remove uh Belorth for a turn. And
also ramp us to eight mana next turn.
Then, we can have Belorth and Cuz at the
same time, you know, we see Sauron with
a lot of mana. If we cast Belorth now,
it might get countered. And if Belorth
gets countered, we are very screwed.
So, I'm thinking we play it safe. The
vampire will hurt, and we might have to
go down to like 15 life or something.
And meanwhile, Belorth might have a
protection spell, but we have to try to
play to our outs, right? And I don't
think running Belorth out there is
correct here. So, we play a land. We can
hold a counter spell again,
in case we need to counter something,
but I doubt it. So, yeah, we pass the
turn. At a turn, we'll sacrifice a
vampire token. Okay, another vampire
demon. Also, I forgot they have flying,
which is very strong. We draw a card for
the sacrifice. Oh, this is very good.
And we describe one.
Mhm, we no longer need the Bloodtracker,
right?
Mhm.
Bloodtracker is also good, actually.
Maybe we keep both. All right.
What's on top? Draw.
Play a land.
Okay, the question is, do we play
Champion first or Vanquisher Banner
first? Champion will draw us a lot of
cards. Six cards. Also, I forgot
something. There was an engine trigger
when I sacrificed the vampire. So,
here's our blood token. Yeah, I'm
thinking we Vanquisher Banner first
because we can't expect to keep the
sport around and we want to do as much
damage as possible while we have a
board. Even if we draw 12 cards, we have
five lands and we're not going to
rebuild very quickly.
So, we'll take a few turns to rebuild.
Yeah, but for now we want to maximize
we want to maximize damage.
So, let's drop the Vanquisher Banner.
Bayezid off draws a card. And let's go
into combat. We want to poke Sorin. We
want to poke Sorin because look at all
this mana. But, like what Bello's doing,
we want to split it so that there's a
higher chance that Sorin will let our
attack through.
So, unfortunately, Bayezid is once again
our punching bag. Okay, so we're going
to send one demon here, one demon this
way, and engine this way.
Meanwhile, oh, we can attack Bello. It's
a free attack, why not?
So, one, two, three, four.
So,
Sorin,
Bayezid, Bello. Bello is kind of our
friend, but
mhm, let's get some damage in. It's not
too much. Who needs blockers? We're
going to mark this vampire.
Oh, also I forgot our vampire plus two
plus two. So, I'll change that a little
bit. This is a 3-3. We can attack
Bayezid. No problem. Okay, and this is
the attack
Sorin doesn't block. Sorin also doesn't
want to use a removal. Take 10. A little
bit risky, but I think we're fine.
Meanwhile, Balor has nothing, so Balor's
going to take five. Belorth takes
another five. Ouch. Not the worst.
Honestly, not the worst scenario. That's
our turn.
Pass. Okay, we've been setting up for
this moment. Let's do it.
Any chance of a counter spell?
Not really. We're not too worried about
that. 1 2 3 4 We have eight mana plus
the one reduction here, so we can pull
for not uh No, seven. Yes. Now,
Vandalblast Rhystic Study.
Might be our last time playing this. I
don't know. I've heard rumors.
4 5 6
Shot 7 8. Okay, this is a solid hand.
We are going to untap, draw. Thunderous
Ignition. This is
for late game.
But
yo, this looks good. Okay, first
question, do we Vandalblast? It's going
to cost us four mana. It ruins Balor and
hurts Belorth, but we're still going to
die to Edgar. Nothing in our hand
actually really stops Edgar. That's a
problem. What if we play our commander?
1 2 3 4 5 6
After our commander, we have three mana
open.
It will allow us to cast these two. Pers
Smarty Command.
Yeah, we can get some combination of
these.
There's no time for Rhystic Study on
this board, but yeah, with a few
blockers, things might get better. Or we
just hold all these responses because
everything is reduced by one, so we can
actually Yeah, we can use all four, I
believe. But none of these are great at
stopping this army.
So, I think we cast Sauron. Yes.
So, Sauron
Don't forget to play
Let's pay mana. Six.
Like this.
And yeah, then we this uh we play a land
and go to discard.
I think it's too late for Mystic Study.
I think Shark Typhoon is too slow with
this hand. It's a win condition. Okay, I
think Signet can go. This doesn't do
enough.
And and let's drop Solemn Divination for
Mystic Study. It's a bit greedy, but I
think with what we have in hand we can
deal with this board. So then we can
Mystic Study and get more value for the
next round of control.
Okay.
Pass. Hollow at the end of turn we are
going to tap.
Uh lose two life, draw card.
We got a Blasphemous Act. Untap, Hollow
comes back and
we draw for turn.
Urza's Workshop. That's not what we need
right now. It is not.
So I think we just enter combat. Yeah,
let's go.
Declare combat. We will send
This time I'm thinking two into Sauron.
No, Sauron can block. Do we send
everything into Sauron? If we do, Hollow
probably doesn't live. We still want to
draw cards. Yeah, this hand is not
enough for card draw. This hand is not
going to do enough.
We might even attack and then
Blasphemous Act ourself.
Because then we can wipe all of this and
hopefully Sauron dies. Yeah, this might
be this might be the correct play, but
for now we need to attack. So I think
it's all three into Baloth,
unfortunately. Yeah, this is kind of
expected. You're just bullying me at
this point. And Baloth over here is
like, "What? Why?" Sauron is going to
take over the game. You're just being
greedy trying to draw cards. And I'm
playing with myself, but I'm getting
salty over here. So
at least yeah, fortunately we do have
this. So we are going to pay four mana
to drop the Talisman Gate. Activate.
And yeah, hoping to phase out Hollow.
And no one has response to that, right?
Seems like it. So, Belbe is phased out
and the attack fizzles. This is where I
think it's a good idea to Blasphemous
Act cuz we have nothing. We cannot
continue to build the board.
Belbe is protected. So, yeah, let's try
that.
Let's pay one red for Blasphemous Act.
And we're not going to pay three extra,
I think.
Yeah, so Belbe can draw a card.
Okay, so this is on the stack. We amass
work one Belbe. We're actually very
happy with this. No responses.
Edgar is not happy with this, but it's
to be expected. Now, the question is do
we sack our board?
We don't touch this, but we can sack a
few things to scry, but not too many
things.
Because
there's a chance that the Blasphemous
Act will get countered.
Actually, I'm thinking we don't sack
anything cuz everything here is really
good. Scrying one is nice, but with what
we have in hand, we don't need the scry
one.
So,
just pass priority. Okay, Sorin is in a
tough spot. Maybe we shouldn't have cast
Sorin.
Confounding Riddle won't even do it. So,
do we just pass?
Do we just let it happen? Yeah, I think
we are still in a decent position
and we can untap with a Vandalblast and
the board is clear. And then we can plop
down a Mystic Study. So, that's a decent
board. Just unfortunately, yeah, the
Sorin dies for nothing.
But, we can't know. Okay.
Nothing dies here. Genius play.
As for Sentinel, if we win this game,
it's all because of this. We drew what?
Seven cards from this and everything
dies. Except we get a Vampire Demon that
sticks around. Draw a card. Pass. Okay,
we continue our turn with Belbe. Do we
play anything?
I still think no. I mean, we play a
land, we play not even the workshop,
just a regular land.
Now, we're going to activate War Room
because because nothing in our hand can
pose a threat. These are rebuild pieces.
So, we pass the turn and just activate
War Room. Okay, Beloth at the end of
turn, we have three mana. We are going
to Valakut Awakening.
We're going to drop all these lands.
Holy, 1 2
Okay, just three, but
three lands
uh Blackblade? Yeah, we can drop that.
We do want the Sheltering Light as
protection.
So, we're dropping I don't think we have
time to play this Mana Rock. Although,
this is a nice draw spell, though.
So, Office Scroll work will keep.
And yeah, we will ship four and draw
five.
Swords protection.
Ultimate magic is very good. Four
shelter.
Five.
Okay, this is a good five. Now, we
didn't get a land, though,
unfortunately. That might have been a
small mistake.
Should have kept one land.
Yeah.
Draw.
We got the land. I am literally John
Finkel. Okay.
Play a land. Okay, so we have the land
and we are going to play our commander.
1 2 3
4 5. Oh, well, not bad, though.
Let's keep red up like this. Okay,
commander on the stack. Now, Sauron
knows how strong Beloth is once it
lands.
So, we want to deal with it and we know
that they have a lot of protection
spells.
So, I think we're going to try
Confounding Riddle just to snipe it from
stack because once it hits, yeah, I
don't think we can I mean, we can remove
it, but it will be a lot of work. So,
let's try that. Confounding Riddle.
Three mana. Counter it unless they pay
four. They only have three mana. Uh this
is very annoying. I think we will have
to
counter that. Yeah, we cannot have our
commander countered. So, Tibalt's
Trickery.
Okay. Yeah, we can stop that. So, let's
roll 1 2 uh D6 yeah, for the three. So
that would be three. So we mill three
cards and get a free spell. One two
three.
Let's get our spell.
Nope.
March of the swirling mist. That's a
whiff. Yeah, so we'll just put them on
the bottom. Okay, our commander does
resolve. Also, we are supposed to
trigger noble heritage. So we put two
counters on the Bayloff. Meanwhile, our
opponents get to decide if they want to
take the deal or not. So how this works
is if there's a chance that you might
attack Bayloff or you you want to do it,
then you don't take it. But if you're
golded anyways or if you don't intend to
attack Bayloff, then it's fine. So Edgar
here I don't think takes the deal and no
one else has creatures. So that happens
and now we have to figure out do we
equip champion's helm or do we save mana
for one of these? Apostle's blessing or
shelter in light?
And I'm thinking champion's helm because
we need a big Bayloff. Otherwise, none
of these is golded. Not even this demon
is golded. Okay, let's equip and hope
for the best.
Pass the turn.
Oh, we have to discard. Discard shelter
and disrupt the quorum. This really
isn't great on this board against
fellow.
We need our commander.
Pass. On top, draw.
Okay, we have a decent hand. We are
going to just rebuild. Yeah, play a land
and rebuild. Start with
scion of opulence. Get a vampire.
Draw a card.
Put this. Yeah, I still think we cast
Yahenni.
So Yahenni.
Three mana.
Uh make a vampire. Draw a card.
This is our hand. Now Yahenni can
attack. It's got haste. It's a three
three.
So I think we go for it.
It is golded, so let's send it into
Sorin.
And we pass the turn. Oh, we get a
treasure, don't we? And we pass the
turn. Sauron untaps, draw.
Good land. Yeah, the vampires rebuild
pretty quickly. I mean, what what what
is this? They have another 15 damage on
board already. If we vandalblast, 1 2 3
4 5, we have five mana open.
We still have mana for
No, we don't. Oh, we can cycle Shark
Typhoon.
And we can
reality shift something? Yeah, but we're
we're fighting a losing battle if we do
that.
Is it time for Sauron again? I'm tempted
to do Sauron again because we really
want to set up for this Chandra's
Ignition. And if we Sauron 1 2 3 4 5 6
7, sorry. That's eight mana. Yeah, this
makes two.
If we do this
and tap properly, I guess.
Uh if we do this, then we will have two
mana open, right? Two mana open.
And with these two mana
we can reality shift and deadly relic.
So, we have two removals if Sauron's
out. And it's not going to die again,
right?
Sauron is pretty difficult to kill. So,
let's try it again.
Yeah. I really want to vandalblast, but
it seems like Bello is kind of running
out of gas.
So,
let's not Sauron and these for commander
tax. Pass the turn.
Bello, we are going to draw with war
room another mana rock. Hmm.
Bello comes back.
Everything is online.
Draw.
Stonespeaker Crystal. You sure? Yeah, we
can get two of them. That's not bad. So,
let's pay four mana. Okay, now we use
the workshop. So, 1 2 3
1 2 3 4 for the Stonespeaker Crystal.
And we get two copies of it because of
Mirrorworks. And I guess we enter combat
to try to draw some cards. And entering
combat, huh, there's the orc here. But
entering combat, I feel like we can only
attack Sauron. Is that right? Yeah, we
have to attack Sauron, right? There's no
other target. We are golden. Yeah, we
can also attack the vampires, but they
have four blockers. So, I think we just
try Yeah, try to do it to Sauron.
So, everyone attack
into Sauron. And maybe we hold a few
back just to lower the threat a little
bit. And also, we want to be able to
winding canyons our bellow in next turn
if he dies.
Winding canyon cost this much and then 1
2 3 4 5 6 mana.
That's not enough. Okay, let's just send
three things in and hopefully Sauron
will let it happen. Sauron sitting at 25
life will not let it happen. So, we have
these two for a reality shift targeting
bellow. At this point, I think hmm
I don't think we dig. I think we just
cuz we can try to dig for a protection
spell, but the chance is not very high.
So, we just let it happen.
Bellow dies or bellow gets exiled.
And we get to manifest, right? This
better not be a protection spell.
It is not.
Good. And it's unfortunate, but we
didn't draw our protection spell for
this game.
Like we had a sweet start, but
protection spell is so important in this
deck cuz it it's so bellow dependent.
Okay, we passed the turn. Bayonetta here
is very very happy with what just
happened in the last two turns. We are
going to untap, we're going to do the
deal. Noble heritage happens. Do you
guys take it? Edgar at this point, I
think we take it. We don't have any way
to deal with Bayonetta and everything is
golden anyways. If we place say two
counters here,
it is this one at least is no longer
golden. Yeah, but it's also not
attacking Bayonetta because Bayonetta is
huge. So, maybe we put it onto our
indestructible man or the one that's
potentially indestructible.
Okay, so Sauron we don't have any desire
to attack Beloth, but we do plan to use
Chandra's ignition.
And if we take the deal, Beloth the
player will not take any damage, will
not lose life, but Beloth
Can we kill Beloth? Beloth is at
five night 11 toughness.
We don't have enough to kill Beloth
anyways.
Although if we put two counters on to
Sauron
and then we use it with Vandalblast.
I guess that could work.
Okay. Yeah, let's let's put two counters
on to Sauron cuz I don't think the army
is going to grow fast enough. Okay, and
Bello doesn't have a creature. So we
play our turn, draw.
Another protection spell, excellent.
Protection, protection, more protection.
And with this board, I don't think we
need to do anything. We can just attack
people. Who do we attack? We want to
make some treasures. I think putting I
think
we want to do some commander damage, and
right now Bello is open. Yeah, we want
to do some damage. I mean getting
treasure is nice, forcing them to jump
block, but
yeah, let's do some damage. So eight
damage into Bello. And for the turn, can
we afford to compass?
See, one, two, three, four, five mana to
compass to get a land? No, I don't think
that's a good idea.
I think we just play it. It becomes a
land, and then we play in all fates
school. Ultimate holy magic is very nice
when you foretell it, but right now we
don't need to because
it's very difficult to kill Beloth, but
Beloth can die to an edict effect,
which is possible. So I think what we do
here is this will turn into a land. So
we foretell this.
Yeah, if Beloth dies, at least we have a
fog. But then we can only cast one of
these, not both.
So, I think we hold the scroll for now.
So, I think we save the compass. We
don't play it just yet. We want to have
our mana open.
So, let's tap two to foretell this.
Ultimate magic holy. Foretell we can use
a book. Very clear.
And then we have four mana for
protection and stuff. Pass the turn.
Okay, vampires we untap with everything.
Yeah.
We want to attack Baylo, but we cannot.
Oh, and I forgot to amass orc here. This
should be on two. And vampires we drew,
we play a land. And
is this the turn for Edgar?
Or
champion of the dusk. If we Edgar, we
are actually just helping Baylo.
But we do need to do damage. If we just
keep doing this, we are going to lose
the late game. So, we have to
Yeah, I think we have to
get some action. And this is a lot of
damage I don't want to waste.
So,
let's pay 1 2 3 4
5 6 for Edgar.
Edgar is on the stack. No responses from
anyone.
And we have to declare combat. Yeah,
Sauron is very worried. Well, meanwhile
we amass one, but we are very worried
because they're golden. So, I think we
have to deadly relic
the Edgar.
Yeah, let's do that. Deadly relic
happens and oh, we do we do still draw
one card.
So, that's that.
And let's enter combat. Sauron is tapped
out. So, our demons can go at Sauron.
Oh, we just have one demon. Sauron is
tapped out, so the demon can go at
Sauron and everything else will just be
blocked, right? Are we more scared of
Sauron or Bello? I honestly honestly I
think it's kind of even.
But Sauron is difficult to get through.
So, looks like we'll have to do
Yeah.
And let's leave a blocker for once.
Yeah, this is not too much damage
anymore now that Edgar's gone.
So we attack, attack. No blocks. Sauron
takes five. Belo takes a lot more.
11.
And why not let's play a blocker.
Although this can't block this interest
tapped. We want to get speed into the
game for maximum confusion. So we get
another vampire token and one speed.
Yeah, let's clean this up a little bit.
Such a mess.
Okay, solid turn. Meanwhile Sauron
analyzes one more. We untap with 20
life. That's That's fine. We're happy
with that.
We draw. So do we carry out our plan to
first vandal blast
and then Chandra's ignition.
Problem is we are not guaranteed to kill
Belo. Belo has protection. And the board
currently is not super scary for us. We
have two blockers. In a pinch we can
also block with shark typhoon.
So maybe we just vandal blast. Yeah, and
we can play a land and hold dig through
time. Vandal blast. 1 2 3 4 5. Oh, in a
pinch cactus preserve can also be a 6 6
blocker.
So five mana, vandal blast on the stack.
Belo's been expecting this. Yeah.
Honestly we're surprised it took this
long. But what we're going to do is we
will
first try to draw card with war room.
This So we're at 11 life. Hmm.
Yeah, we still need to draw.
Draw card.
And then we are going to crack the Stone
Speaker Crystal
to exile all of our opponent's
graveyards.
Sauron we have to think about do we dig
through time? If we don't then we won't
be able to.
I'm thinking we do.
Yeah, we need to see what we can get,
what answers we can get.
Cuz our hand isn't very good right now.
So, Dig Through Time, exiling delving
six things,
looking at top seven cards.
Free counter spell,
four,
five,
six.
Oh, boy. Cyclonic Rift.
Yeah, I think it's Cyclonic Rift and our
free counter spell, Force of Negation.
Okay, so then we exile the rest of our
graveyard.
No more graveyard. No more graveyard.
And
Bello has no more responses. Beloth, do
we have a response to Vandalblast? I'm
tempted to do this,
Blacksmith's Skill. Yeah, I think it's
worth it. So, let's do that
to protect our Champion's Helm.
No responses.
Uh
happens. Everything else gets blown up.
So, this is gone.
We lose all this. Holy.
And this.
Rough. And Beloth also loses a few
things here
and here.
Not the worst outcome.
Okay, and
Work Army is golded, so we have to send
this into
somebody.
Yeah, there's no point attacking
vampires, so I guess we send it into
Bello. We've messed with them enough,
I'm sure.
The relationship isn't too good over
here. So, we attack Bello. So, Bello
takes four.
Pass the turn.
Bello untaps.
Draw.
Return Ugin.
Sorry, this is exiled.
Uh does this do anything? Not really.
Yeah, I think we're just dead. I guess
Ugin can make a blocker. Sure, we have
two blockers. Let's hold the fort.
So, six mana.
Ugin will plus becomes a two-two. It's a
stone calendar. Okay, remember this is a
two-two.
Uh we'll use Mishra's Workshop.
One mana.
I'll use one mana on Cloud Key naming
artifacts.
But our artifacts are free anyways.
So, let's not do the Cloud Key.
Let's just cast these two for free.
The two diamonds and play a land.
And pass the turn. Okay, Bayaloth
untaps. We didn't even have to cast
anything.
This is a very good sign. We'll use the
Cure Cube to make a token. Let's get a
sad Kobold cuz he knows he's a chump
blocker. Okay, Bayaloth untaps.
And Noble Heritage triggers. Bayaloth
goes to 10 power.
And
the hacker doesn't want to take the deal
cuz
I know everything is golden, but we have
to try to find a way to kill Bayaloth.
Right, with edict or whatever.
Otherwise, we are not winning the game.
Or maybe
maybe we just
kill Sauron and then hope to raise
Bayaloth. That's another possibility.
Honestly, I think that might be more
feasible than trying to kill the
creature. Yeah.
Okay, I changed my mind. I'm going to
put two more counters onto
the Henny
and make the deal with Bayaloth.
Meanwhile, Sauron says, "Sure, why not?
Let's do it." And also, I should
remember to amass orc. We amassed three
here. My apologies from Belos's turn.
Always a little bit behind here. We have
our own time zone for the orc. Okay, so
we draw.
Oh, we drew an onto inversion. Mhm.
One, two, three, four, five.
Unfortunately, we lost our mana rocks.
Otherwise, we could have cleared the
board while
protecting
Bay off, kind of.
So, with the board as is,
I think we
play a Mirage Mirror
and pass.
Yeah, Mirage Mirror is nutty. So, let's
do that. 1 2 3. Do we play the compass?
I want to say no
because I want to hold up Kira-Key.
The only way for Bay off to die now
really is Edict
because remember what we have here.
So, we want to be prepared for
all kinds of situations, I guess. So,
let's attack with Bay off to force a
block.
And I think the target we should attack
is Sauron. The Sauron is a 10/9 with
mana open.
Doesn't feel safe. Maybe we just attack
Edgar
to get a treasure.
No, we want Edgar to go all in at
Sauron. So, we attack Bello to get a
treasure. Now, let's bully the Bello.
Attack Bello.
Bello blocks with
this.
Goes to hand.
And we get a treasure.
Yeah, our problem here is we don't have
a
reliable way to end the game.
But, currently, I think this board is
fine.
But, at the moment, we are okay with
this board
staying as is. And the Mirage Mirror can
do some ridiculous stuff.
I'm not sure what, but we'll find
something to do with it.
Edgar untaps.
Draw.
Midgar.
Okay, I want to play a Crossway
Troublemakers. 1 2 3 4 5 6.
Because then
we can gain a bunch of life.
Which is not super relevant cuz Bay off
kills by commander damage.
But, it also draws us cards. We can Uh
do we have a side outlet? Oh, we do.
Yes, Yahenni. Yes. So, we can draw a lot
of cards if we need to.
But, for now we have to attack. Yeah, I
think we just try to kill two opponents.
So, we are going to
Yeah, Belbe seems pretty dead. So, we
are going to do the bare minimum.
Scion
and tokens
at Belbe.
Gas, Guzzler, too. So, this will be
five attackers.
And
Belbe can block one, but it will still
be five damage. So, this kills the
Belbe.
And these two at
at Sauron. Oh, and we have one more
token to block with. Okay, this is our
combat.
Uh Belbe will block the Scion of
Opulence. Seems reasonable.
And Edgar, we are going to sacrifice the
Scion so that
the blocker doesn't die and Belbe
doesn't get an extra treasure. Cuz Belbe
is dead anyways. Right? So, we sacrifice
the Scion.
Then what happens is we uh this is
indestructible now. Yahenni, and we get
to draw a card and we lose LP to life,
draw a card.
Okay, another land.
Uh meanwhile, Sauron, we are being
attacked by these two. Sauron can block
this. We can take three.
And we don't need to use anything.
Yeah, we can hold this and we can rift
after, right?
So, we block Yahenni and we take
four.
Meanwhile, a lot of life linking
happens.
Five
plus six, 11, plus four, 15 life.
And yeah, from that Belbe profits a
little bit.
Hey, Edgar passes the turn.
Sauron at the end of turn doesn't do
anything. We un
Maybe we cycle this land.
Sure.
Cycle the land.
Draw a card.
Okay.
We are cooking.
We got the One Ring.
Sweet. Draw for turn.
Arcane Denial.
Yeah, I think we Chandra's Ignition and
then One Ring.
And hold a counter spell.
Or is Cyclonic Rift better? No, then we
don't have mana for One Ring.
So,
let's get the ring out.
We draw a card.
That's a land.
Sure, we'll play it as a land because
then we also have Cyclonic Rift.
Now, do we
prefer Ignition? I don't think so
because it doesn't kill
Yahenni, doesn't kill Beläf.
So, yeah, we are going to ring and rift.
The ultimate control play.
Unfortunately, we took the deal so we
cannot attack Beläf, but why not? Let's
attack
Edgar.
Edgar will block. Edgar will block the
Sauron.
Gain one life.
Oh, whoops. And take this seven damage.
The vampire dies, we draw a card, lose
two life.
Sauron.
Meanwhile, Beläf gets one more treasure.
Okay, Sauron passed the turn.
At the end of turn, we are going to use
the Mirage Mirror to copy
the One Ring.
Sauron, do we allow that? Yeah, I think
now is too early to rift, so let's wait.
We'll draw a card with the One Ring.
The land on top.
Once again, time for deals. Placing two
counters here.
For vampires, yeah, I don't think
there's any point. Let's not do it.
And Sauron also doesn't want to do it
because we can potentially hurt Belorth
a lot.
So, no one's taking it.
And now we draw for turn.
We drew the Ironcrag.
We play a land.
Now, is this the turn for Undue
Inversion? We can pay 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
mana
and we can use this to protect our
board.
But
with
but knowing that Sauron has so much mana
up, I feel like
this is not going to fire.
I feel like this will be disrupted.
So, I think we just
pass and see. Hopefully, Edgar gets the
job done.
But, let's play a compass.
And uh
and I think that's fine. We are we're
okay with passing here.
And sure, let's play the Ironcrag as
well.
Tap a little bit better. We can't attack
Sauron, so we send Belorth into Edgar.
Edgar takes
12 commander damage.
The compass wants to transform.
Now,
Sauron, do we respond to the
transformation?
I think it's fine if we do that now.
Yeah, we are honestly at this point not
that worried about Edgar. We are mostly
worried about Belorth.
And we still have a counter spell back
up. So, let's do it now. Cyclonic Rift.
Oh, and also a mass works two more.
Cyclonic Rift on the stack.
Belorth says, "No, this is not good."
How do we respond?
Do we try to kill Sauron?
Okay, let's see. So, first we crack two
treasures. This will turn into the One
Ring
and we are going to use it.
Draw two cards.
None of these will save us.
So, we are going to Swords to Plowshares
the Sauron.
Sacrificing our One Ring.
Amass.
And
Sauron, do we counter it?
I think we do because we're potentially
presenting lethal against that one.
So,
yeah, let's counter it.
The The The Mystic Study.
And Force of Negation. Oh, yeah. This is
sacrificed anyways because it's part of
the cost.
And Swords is countered.
And it looks like yeah, we float mana.
It looks like we have nothing to do, so
we float mana.
Returns to hand.
And everything else back to hand.
And we have to discard. Oh, that was
disgusting, Sauron. Let's first go to
the vampires. So, we have a chance to
respond. Do we respond?
Yeah, let's sack the tokens at least.
Sack sack sack.
Sack four tokens.
Uh draw Okay, one at a time. Draw.
That's good.
One more.
Sure.
Let's do one more.
Reeca.
And this Reeca gives us a lot more
confidence because we can make Sauron
sack creature, so we can draw one more.
Okay.
Solid. And everything else returns to
hand.
Okay, now it's time for Baloth to end
the turn with this card. Now, we do have
two floating mana, but this is our end
step, so we can make a cobalt. But, how
much does this cost? This costs three
mana, so no. We are not making a cobalt.
We're just going to discard down, so we
lose two protection spells
and uh compass, I guess. Pass the turn.
Edgar Markov, we will rebuild. We will
always rebuild. Draw.
Play a land
into a Sol Ring.
And we've got
Gas Guzzler. We've got Falkenrath Pit
Fighter.
We'll make the tokens later.
But most importantly,
we have Henrika.
We get three tokens here and amass works
three. This is now at 13. And uh we
don't have haste, but we have this card.
Order of the Sacred Dusk costs six mana,
but with convoke, so we can pay three
four five six
seven
eight.
That's right.
Eight mana. Oh, okay, we'll do do it
like this. Eight.
And this enters. One more amass, one
more vampire. Now, as we enter combat,
we're going to trigger Henrika to make
each player sacrifice a creature. I will
sacrifice this ugly vampire to save the
pretty ones.
And Sorin sacrifices oof, that's tricky.
I think we sacrifice the army, honestly.
Yeah, sack the army. He cannot attack
Sorin, so we'll send this into Beloth.
And how big is it? 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
exalted, so 12 damage. Now, Beloth has
to think about this. Do we fog? We do
have some life gain here, but
honestly, I think we fog and then onto
inversion. Sorin is scary, but it can't
do Can Sorin do
20 damage to us?
Also possible. Um you know what? We are
not dead. Let's take it. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12. And we gain 12 life, Edgar.
Half a turn. Speed two.
Actually, our speed should be probably
four by now. Yeah, I'm pretty sure we
are at speed four.
So, I keep forgetting that speed that it
doesn't matter if the Gasguzzler is on
the field. Speed just grows on its own.
So,
yeah, speed four. Max speed. Sauron
untaps.
Take your damage, but we are going to
draw immediately.
Draw two.
Land.
Yeah, I think we're doing pretty well
here.
Let's play a different land. Let's play
Rivendell.
But, now we can just attack into Baloth
and see what happens, right? So, Sauron
attacking to Baloth. Baloth is going to
use our Fortold card.
Ultimate magic. Holy. And, Sauron will
send an Arcane Denial.
And, Baloth is dead. Yeah, I think we
messed up there.
Should have done this to prevent the 12
damage, but I don't think it matters too
much. We are
not going to be able to keep up.
Yeah, I don't think we can keep up with
this. Yeah, that rift was brutal. We
needed to Furious Protection there.
But, yeah. Okay, let's pack it up.
And, meanwhile, we are going to
press on with our advantage. We should
have amassed Orc one here, but it
doesn't matter cuz we are going to
Thunder's Ignition, right?
One, two, three, four.
Five.
And, we still have a blocker here in
Cactus Preserve.
Yeah, our our hand is a little bit empty
at this moment, but I think we're fine.
So, let's do 10 damage to everything
using Sauron. Edgar says,
"Whoops."
Okay, it happens.
Everything is dead.
And we take ten.
Okay, Sauron passed the turn. Oh, also
Edgar should have discarded last turn.
Uh I I guess
land land Yeah, my apologies.
One more.
Yeah, now Edgar untaps.
Sauron is at 15 without too much going
on.
Just a Sauron. Ooh, we got Queen Spey
Paladin.
Okay, that's something that's something.
So, we
Can we afford to pay more life? I'm sure
we Yeah, paying life is fine.
Paying life is fine.
God was trying.
Paladin 1 2 3
4 5
Vampire token and a mass orc. Now, the
Paladin will bring back a vampire, which
will be
order of Oh, is it Henrika?
Unfortunately, they amassed orc. So,
do we have a way to kill the orc? I
don't think so. So, let's take the order
instead.
Order of the sacred dusk. And let's also
play a crossway troublemakers.
Why not?
It's a good card. Make a token, a mass
orc two.
So, let's send the Paladin in
for
1 2 3 4 5 uh exalted five? Yes.
No, exalted four, sorry. And it's a 99.
Yeah, we have to block. Sauron has to
block and gain nine.
Pass the turn. Okay, at the end of turn,
Sauron, do we do anything?
I guess we can amass. Sure, let's amass
orcs X.
X is going to be just one.
It's over here.
And we untap. Lose two life.
Draw.
Yeah, let's draw more. 1
Yeah, I think Shark Typhoon will get us
there.
Right, let's play a land.
Let's play
a 1 2 3 4
Shark Typhoon
And we have counter spell, we have a
copy spell
giving double strike to something
relevant and behold the multiverse.
Do we foretell? I guess we can foretell
that. Sure, foretell.
Behold the multiverse.
What can possibly go wrong? And Sauron
should attack. Should we attack? Yeah,
let's block. If we attack, we're just
giving them one more card. Pass the
turn. Edgar untaps.
Draw.
Anguish on making.
See, I'm thinking should we
So, I'm thinking should we try to kill
Sauron? There's no legend we can sack.
Maybe not. Maybe not.
Uh we should just attack all in, I'm
thinking.
Is Edgar a good idea? Edgar 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8
And Queen's Bay will return something.
What can we return that's really good?
Nothing.
Nothing too crazy. Enrica?
Falconrath? Okay, let's try to draw some
cards.
Five mana
for
Champion of the
Dusk. If it resolves, we could draw 1 2
3 4 5 6 6 cards. Now, Sauron, do we do
something about that? We can try.
To dig for something?
Yeah, let's dig a little bit.
We're doing it anyways because we need
to make a shark. So, let's do this.
Behold the multiverse. Scry two. Nope.
Bottom, bottom.
Draw two. Oops. A masked orc from the
spell
and we might be
We might be screwed. And here, Edgar, we
draw six lose six.
1 2
3 4
5 6
Mirror entity is sweet.
Does that
win us the game?
We cast it.
We can turn our our whole board into
3/3s. Not quite. Next turn, it will, but
not this turn.
So, with what we have here
I'm tempted to drop Yahenni. That will
make us a vampire.
And now we need to separate what can
attack and what cannot attack.
These ones can attack.
3 4 5
Okay, and I guess we send them in. Yeah,
we are not afraid of dying. Go, go, go.
Attack, attack, attack.
And Queen's Blade Paladin triggers.
We'll bring back
Scion of Opulence.
The board is actually such a mess. Let's
widen this a little bit.
Okay, so this is the front line.
And everything else back here
I think the Scion is actually very good
here. So, the vampires have lifelink.
Oh, and we lose three life.
So, Sorin is going to block this one,
Queen's Blade Paladin.
And the orc, which should be a 3/3 now,
will block Oh, sorry. Yahenni is also
attacking cuz haste. So, this will be
blocked.
And the flying fish will block a 5/5
jump block.
Sure, we'll block a 5/5.
So, that we take
five
six seven damage. Oh, that hurts. Holy
crap.
Yeah, seven damage.
And meanwhile, the life the vampires
will link 19 life. This will die.
We make a treasure.
Actually, the hand will sack something
to protect itself. We link one less
life, they lose one less life.
The shark dies.
The hand will get a counter.
And that's the combat.
We discard and pass.
Okay, things are rough. We on top.
We lose three life.
We have one turn to kill the vampires. I
don't think we can.
It's possible with Sauron commander
damage, but
uh not sure how we're going to do it.
Draw.
Oh.
Blasphemous Act. Um
How's that going to save us?
Well,
there's always the
wandering with Minamo. So, we're going
to draw
one, two,
three, four, and we're going to Minamo.
We're going to Minamo the
wandering and draw five.
Holy.
We drew the Mount Doom.
But, we played a land already,
unfortunately.
Let's see what's in the graveyard. Not
much. Ignition.
Ooh.
Ignition is uh
Psychic Rift.
Okay, I think we have a game plan.
Uh
So, let's play a Sol Ring first. Whoops.
It's not here yet. Sol Ring.
And we play
uh this.
Chakra meditation.
And
we'll make some sharks, but I don't
think it matters cuz we are getting back
Chandra's ignition. We are going to
Chandra's ignition on the Sorin.
Let's see. Yeah, pay mana. 1 2
3 4 5.
Maybe tap correctly.
Chandra's ignition on the Sorin.
And
we draw a card and discard a card. Draw
a land, destroy discarded.
Any responses?
This is actually tough because we can
anguish on making the Sorin,
but we have to sacrifice our Yahenni.
Cuz our Yahenni would live if uh, we
don't do that.
But I think Yeah, I think we try. We
try. So,
pay three for anguish on making.
Um, the Sorin.
Sacrificing Yahenni.
And when we do that,
we get a treasure. Sorin will amass orc.
One more. And of course, we have a Swan
Song.
Swan Song happens and
yeah.
That's countered.
And this turns into a swan, which will
die.
And no more responses from vampires.
So, this resolves.
The orc dies, graveyard. Oh, also, we
need to get to loot once. So, draw
uh, discard
a land.
Here is our hand, and the board is
wiped. So, the vampire takes
10 damage here.
And we lose 1 2 3 4 vampires, non-token
vampires.
And two tokens. Uh three tokens.
So, we get four treasures. Now, do we
draw cards? We're at 38 life. We'll take
another 10 from Sauron. Yeah, let's draw
a few. Draw Let's see. One,
two,
three,
four.
Okay, this is a good draw. Um
Yeah, I think we're okay with that.
Then, Sauron will attack for 10 damage.
Let's take commander damage.
And Sauron is at four life, but we are
okay because we have Got Rewrites
History.
Yeah, that's what we're banking on.
Uh but Mountain would have been sweet.
We We don't get to though because it's
too late.
And we also have a Gearhulk that we
can't use this turn.
Okay, it's a little bit dangerous
actually cuz we don't have a lot of mana
left.
We'll see.
Pass.
Uh discard.
Um
Discard.
Two.
Like this.
Pass. This game is actually very close.
Untap.
Draw.
Knowing Sauron is at four life with a
One Ring, we just try to do any amount
of damage. So, let's play a land first.
And we get a Demonic Tutor. Let's use
the tutor.
Yes. So, let's search for something that
can attack, I guess.
Sisters of the Undead
seems like a decent target.
Okay, I like that. Okay, we're going to
cast Sisters of the Undead. Six mana.
Now Sorin
I think we can go with that if they
declare combat. So, let's wait.
Resolves, we get a vampire token.
And let's also do this.
4 5 4
Patriarch's Bidding.
Okay. Oh, let's take a look at Sorin's
graveyard first.
See, that's the sad part about Sorin.
Sorin does not have friends.
Yeah, there's nothing. Meanwhile, we
have everything. Oh, Sorin, we have to
counter that, right? Yeah, but
unfortunately, we are one mana short. We
don't have
counter spell mana and Guff Rewrites
History mana. Yes, unfortunately, we are
just one mana short. Otherwise, we'd be
able to counter spell the
Bidding and also use Guff Rewrites
History. So, as is, it looks like we are
dead.
And that's it. I'm actually really
surprised Edgar was able to take the
game with the two control decks on the
board. And Belbe definitely felt behind
every step of the way, especially with
the Cyclonic Rift. That's something
that's very difficult to protect
against. And that just wrecked us. And
also, we had some difficulty golding
Belbe, which led to a lot of damage
taken in the early game. Yeah, so we
needed Belbe out earlier. Maybe more
ramp, maybe we need that. But at the
end, Sorin seemed to have things under
control, but Edgar managed to sneak in
enough damage to get there. Overall, I
think the game showcased how every deck
plays, and we will definitely run it
back to give Belbe one more chance.
I'll see you in the next video.